one of the things that blew my mind
probably the most ridiculous statistic
we've ever uncovered is that eighty
percent of american workers get paid
more than fifteen dollars an hour
because the the uh the narrative the
kind of mainstream coverage is oh we
have to raise the minimum wage fifteen
bucks and the free market essentially
has already established 15 dollars an
hour is the kind of going rate and so
when you see as you mentioned um going
from 15 to 17
it feels uh in some weird way that
people uh are thinking all the time like
john always talks about his friends they
don't invest in anything unless they
think he's going up 10x right which
again like like there's there's uh
one aspect of like they're probably not
wrong right of like if you're young and
you can buy assets and you hold them for
long enough like you probably can get
those types of returns over a long
period of time but they're not looking
for it over a long period of time
looking for a short period of time so
there's a psychological impact to just
everything goes up uh but if you could
literally take a dollar and put it in
something that you think whether it
actually happens or not it goes up 10x
what's the difference between 15 to 17
like there almost is no difference in
terms of trying to to get you to
incentivize to come and actually work
right absolutely and that's the problem
they're gonna have to deal with because
a lot of younger people are starting to
see that i mean we have the whole nft
craze right now people i know a 15 year
old with a hundred thousand dollars you
really think he'll get him to work at
mcdonald's right now you know he might
buy mcdonald's exactly that's what i'm
saying so it's sort of a weird dynamic
i'm seeing these younger people getting
into a game earlier than their you know
parents their grandparents and their
it's money behind it it's not like other
technology where oh if you had a cell
phone first whatever you talk to your
parents how to use their cell phones now
it's like no i'm teaching my parents how
to make more money i make more than them
so uh that's sort of weird but it is
crazy to see things change so take like
a 15 year old like that is that
something where uh they just playing on
the internet they see stuff they learn
themselves or somebody you know a friend
a family friend whatever saying to them
hey look you should go do this you're a
young person you understand like how do
they get into it you think oh yeah well
that particular 15 year old i'm talking
about i taught his mom at a seminar
about bitcoin she brought him to the
next one talking about bitcoin and he
just would call me text me every now and
then like what should i do blah blah
blah introduce him to the nfts and he
went crazy because that was more his
creative side and he figured it out a
lot of the drops and things that go with
that and yeah he's sitting at about 100k
worth of crypto right now and then as
far as bitcoin our only argument is i
always tell them man you should stick
with bitcoin blah blah blah
you know what kids are just like no no
i'm getting chiba i'm getting whatever i
like the dog i like
but like you said your friends don't
invest unless it's a 10x that's the same
kind of mindset yes why not gamble i'm
15. like what am i really losing at this
point i have way more than my peers so
uh hey more power to him yeah when you
talk to like a 15 year old like that how
much of it is around they're trying to
actually learn investing and they're
kind of exploring markets versus they're
actually just saying hey look i want to
make money because i want to go and buy
other stuff like are they doing it to
build a portfolio are they doing it so
they can go buy cool you know he's gonna
go buy a car exactly it's usually the
latter but the good thing i always say
is at least their their foot is in the
door at least they saw it's sort of the
medicine in the candy if i can get you
with nfts or i can get you with oh
you're making a lot of money what you're
actually doing is teaching yourself what
investing is whether you do it well or
not you're still teaching yourself and
then sort of guiding them to that way
because again kids you can't hit them
with the hard facts federal reserve is
doing this get into bitcoin save they're
not going to listen you have to get them
in some way creative and being a former
teacher i see how that works you just
get them in there and then once they're
in you teach them what they need to know
so
it's usually the latter i mean when i
was 15 i was going to buy shoes and dump
[ __ ] too so i understand that but just
trying to shift it a little bit to where
it's like hey hey if you're actually
thinking long term you can be pretty
wealthy if you know what you're doing
yeah because it's almost like you're
teaching them the skill set of investing
and now the barrier to entry to invest
has come down so significantly that uh
literally a 15 year old can do it and
then you add in these like super
asymmetric opportunities whether they're
sustainable or not and you take a couple
thousand dollars or a couple hundred
dollars in some cases and bam next thing
you know you're like hey i'm sitting on
a real portfolio that other folks would
spend years working and i'm 15 i'm 16
i'm 20. you know there's plenty of
people at 25 years old and they're just
like you know wait what just happened
exactly i mean wealth we've never seen
before and again some of the people who
are you know around our age 30s 40
whatever most of them have never seen
this before but they lived during the
time where you know technology took so
they understand that it's coming it's
sort of the the boomer generation that's
like i don't understand how
my 401k is this but this little kid is
making you know 60 80. so that interests
him as well so it all works uh in his
favor you know bitcoin wins at the end
so